so
reddit any sentence that starts with
reddit you know it's going to be fun
the the top question on the cardano
subreddit
which is quite a wonderful place by the
way uh was
can you get charles to play devil's
advocate
against cardano if it's going to fail
what would uh failure look like and what
are the most likely
reasons it would fail okay well there's
the
failure for example i said one of the
project goals was
to achieve self-evolution so if it
doesn't achieve that where it can evolve
itself iteration by iteration
then obviously the product didn't do
what was intended
if it continuously required the
supervision of custodians in order
for it to succeed the system just won't
work the good news is we have a lot of
data showing the opposite
you know we used to run a federated
model and now we're completely
decentralized for block production
but that didn't just happen overnight i
mean there was a whole process
with the incentivized test net and the
stateful pioneers program
and the launch of shelling and the
decrementing of the decentralization
parameter
and every step of the way people showed
up and had to do things and we went from
several to thousands
of people who are regularly maintaining
the infrastructure but there's no
guarantee
that that would be sustainable and
there's no guarantee that
the next step the smart contract step
will achieve what we want and the next
step the governance step will achieve
what we want
i mean it's an experiment and all these
types of things all cryptocurrencies all
companies
are in a sense experiments when they are
evolving the business model
and as our case our our businesses
systems and society
we're offering to the world a vision of
how to run humanity in a different way
and the only way the system can do that
is by millions of people joining the
system
self evolving the system and growing it
in that particular direction
another failure scenario would be the
system evolves in the wrong direction
so it's self-evolving but it goes into a
more centralized dystopian
way and that's that's problematic as
well what would that look like what
would dystopia the
self-evolution total dystopia look like
a small group of actors have total
control over who gets to use the system
and how they get to use the system and
your use of the system is monitored and
shared with that small group of actors
so social credit in china is a great
example of that a small group of people
have access to that
and then your experience in chinese
society is determined by it
so that's an example of a failure mode
and another could be just
network effect we we start experiencing
a churn rate
and the you know inputs don't match the
outputs and that
you lose more than you gain and then
over time the system dies off
however that's really hard in practice
once you reach a certain network effect
even if you become stagnant and stale
you tend not to lose your users and
our evangelism is unbelievable in the
cardinal community i think we're number
one for tattoos
you know and this if you think about
that it's a strange metric to have
but there are brands that associate that
way like apple and harley davidson and
so forth people tend to actually tattoo
the logo
those people don't leave they they don't
actually walk away from the ecosystem
they're fanboys to the core
so there's a there's a lot of of people
that are here for life they don't care
if it's dollar aida two cent data
and they believe in the mission vision
and value of what we wish to achieve and
they've become evangelists in that
respect
so the question is does that community
sustain itself
and also does that community not make
the same sense and mistake of
bitcoin where they become toxic and
maximalistic and they start becoming
highly religious
about whatever beliefs they have my hope
is our community will be
open and socratic and love the
scientific method and be willing to
entertain ideas without adopting them
and discard ideas that are proven to be
wrong
if we become dogmatic and embrace an
orthodoxy that
is counterproductive innovation then
it'll stall out the ecosystem
and you'll notice i never said price in
any of this i never said hey
you know the failure is if the price
goes way down and
success is if the price goes way up
that's unfortunately the metric that
most people use but i couldn't care less
about it
because you know if the reality is if
you construct a system that
encompasses the entire globe and has
billions of users it's probably going to
be a pretty valuable system
that's a you know a secondary thing you
know it's an after effect of
having success in adoption using utility
unfortunately most people on reddit and
twitter and other channels
they tend to just judge your entire
success based on that i had very few
people when shelley launched even though
it took us four years to get there
a lot of work say congratulations on
shelly but i had a lot of people when
ada reached the dollar say we're so
proud of you amazing work
congratulations and so forth and that's
probably the most disheartening thing
about uh the the whole being around and
doing this stuff
where all the things you do only matter
as long as it's making someone else rich
and
and in a way i feel almost like a
failure uh you know because
that that mindset means that we
haven't yet inculcated the community in
a proper way
saying hey guys this is about more than
money it's about more than the value of
ada what we're attempting to do here is
re-engineer the way society works i'd
like your voting to be different i'd
like your property to be different i'd
like you on your cell phone to have a
universal wallet
and when you go to starbucks or wherever
you can buy your coffee with silver or
gold or
airline miles or something like that and
they get paid whatever the hell they
want to get paid and i want those rails
to be done with a system that puts you
in charge not someone else
and they say yeah that's all fine and
great as long as eight is five dollars
we're we're all happy
you see so that that's a problem there
are of course other things that could
fail like you know
we could lose project cohesion lots of
people could quit and die but again
there's so much momentum there's so many
things
here the ideas are already out there and
there's no intellectual property
you know when you publish 100 papers you
write a million lines of code that's
something and it's permanent
and it's in the commons now so it's just
as much yours as it is mine
so there's no notion that somehow you
know if the core development company
disappeared
then that concept is lost forever like
for
like the library of alexandria burning
to the ground it's it's there
and someone else will take it fork it
and get it done
i mean first of all that's fascinating
the self-evolution you don't know which
trajectories that's going to take
but also there's could be singular
singular events
like bugs in the system create
an opportunity to hack the system is
that something that you see as a
potential
uh failure case yeah it's always a
possibility bugs can exist there can be
flaws in the protocol design zcash was a
great example of that where there was a
subtle
flaw and it damaged the fidelity of the
cryptocurrency in ways no other
cryptocurrencies ever experienced
normally when you have a bug um the bug
you can see it like the bitcoin overflow
the value overflow incident yes bitcoin
can be created but we can verify they
weren't
so the monetary policy is preserved when
you have a bug with a private system
like zcash and it exists on the shielded
side there's no guarantee unless you can
audit the total supply inside that field
inside minor cities you can't
that somebody didn't exploit the bug and
create trillions of these coins out of
thin air and just hiding them on that
system and dripping them out
and so the monetary policy is forever
damaged as a consequence of book like
that it's probably the worst type of bug
you can have for these types of products
so you know no matter how good of a job
you do they have great scientists there
are great people there
great engineers there you can always
have something like that seep its way
and leak its way in
and that lurks in the distance but you
know if that's a
problem shared with every one of your
neighbors that's true you know this so i
it's like everybody working on a nuclear
power plant well yeah you can all die of
radiation poisoning well we all kind of
knew that didn't we
you know so yeah so it's it's like i i
don't really think too much about it you
know i i think the context of the
question was more what is cardano
specific over ethereum or bitcoin or any
of these other things and yeah okay
existential lurking bug could happen
it's lower probability for us
than the other systems because we use
formal methods and we use peer review
inside the
the protocol design so there's been more
eyeballs and tools and techniques used
to check things and
we actually have discovered a lot of
weird wonky bugs before production
and resolve those bugs so it shows you
the system works
it's a lot of fun
you